all right Amber
Amber oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I'm from Paterson
New Jersey
Patterson and tell me about your family
growing up
um I grew up without my mom or a dad my
dad was deported a little after birth
and my mom was such a heavy drug user
that she was and out of rehab and out of
prison
so I had a wonderful woman adopt me and
my sister
and she made life
as best as it could have been despite of
everything else that I've gone through
how would you describe your childhood
with the adopted mom my adopted mom
perfect I always had food always had a
roof over my head
she was
greatly unto God so she instilled that
into us
she worked very hard and she like I said
she made the best life that she could
have made for us for you and your my
sisters and your sisters okay
do you ever meet your biological parents
um I've never seen my dad
but I've had encounters with my
biological mother
what kind of kid were you in high school
very athletic very quiet
but I had a temper
um
but yeah I was just very athletic you
could call me like the Tomboy everybody
saw me as either the soccer player or a
basketball player and that's how people
would describe me the short Spanish
basketball player
but they didn't know what was happening
despite a basketball you know basketball
was my place of
Safe Haven I guess you can say what was
going on behind the scenes
um like I said my biological mother was
a heavy drug user so
during the times that she was using she
wasn't like really on top of who was
near and who was around were you with a
someone else who raised you say that
again weren't you raised by someone else
yes I was raised by my adopted mother
right but she had visitation right
throughout that yeah
so
during the times that she was able to
see us she took advantage like she
completely didn't even
like she wasn't on top of who was around
us who she left us with and little
things was happening here and there like
that's when like the whole touching and
I was around eight nine years old at
this time
um
you know men touching me
telling me that um
this is things that my my mother wanted
to happen you know feeding me
your your adopted mom wasn't in the
picture to protect you
she wasn't in a picture to protect me
like I said she had visitation rights so
she had a right to take us oh for the
weekend or throughout the week so
so what kind of stuff is going on yeah
so
um while she was using and with her
friends you know there were other men
around so
they started to like touch me and make
me touch them
later on Oro was introduced I think
around like 10
. um
but like I said she just wasn't on top
of things that she should have been as a
mom
what was your mom's drug
um PC PCP crack cocaine
um
pretty sure like Molly and all that like
everything pretty much any one of those
will do the trick yeah
anything that will get her to where she
needs to be
and how did that
that got older it definitely caused like
a ripple effect in my life like I said
she got into a relationship when I was
13 or
11 I believe
with a female like all her all our lives
we know her to be with men and she had
eight kids all of us by men so
out of nowhere she did she was with a
woman but that woman had a older son
and
during those times of visitations when I
got older it was easy for him
to like come on to me because of what I
previously experienced with
my biological mother friends while she
was getting high
so being under the same roof and him
being the aggress like the aggressive
person that he was
he was
able to lure me groom me into
you know having sex with me
um
and
I didn't say anything because I just
felt like this is what happens when I'm
with my biological mothers
like I said from younger this was
happening so I didn't think anything
different was going to come from
it almost becomes normalized right it
was definitely normal for me at that
time
and then I went to high school
and
security guard
immediately
it's like it's like people can see
that I I don't know this is it felt it
feels like people can see that I'm an
easy target
if you know what I mean so
um
it was easy for him to
do what he did as well for two or three
years
while you're in high school
and you never said anything to anyone I
said something to a teacher but
the like the first year and the first
time that it happened I told the teacher
and nothing happened it wasn't until I
told my best friend and my best friend
until
the an administrator
but that was three years later
you know I spoke up the first time
nothing happened so I just felt like
hair again normal something that's
supposed to happen
um
and then trickled down to
going to college me thinking that I can
change
what happens in my life going to college
and that wasn't the case I met a guy
and
he was a high blood bank member
um
and in the beginning it was it was it
was nice you know he he did the whole
providing
gifts so and that was something new to
me like I was always a person giving
giving giving giving
and I finally had somebody who I thought
appreciated me loved me
so
um
it wasn't until maybe seven months until
our relationship he was like
you know I think
this can be bigger than us like saying
that we should get into like porn
pornography and make some money off of
just us too
and
me being a naive person that I was
I was I was for it
um but it turned out to be something
that
wasn't
what was explained
it started to become all my friends or
um this girl really likes you
can we can we try something with you to
understand the third and then the king
to his friends and then it came on to
something bigger
um
one of the first times that I was sold
was maybe a year after dealing with him
um
I was so too
I mean I'm not going to say means first
like safety reasons but I also to
a higher
Frank person but not in Bloods but I
will say more like Mafia
um
and
out of all the people that I was sold to
that was probably the best experience
that I could have got out of that kind
of experience if you know like
there was no beatings no like they
really was focused on the parents like
you're the money maker you are the
person that
you know essentially is bringing this
money in so they really held up to that
they they didn't like I said they didn't
beat us they didn't do Scare Tactics
it's like it wasn't anything like that
and
get it like they took money from us but
they always made sure that we were okay
they didn't treat us like dogs so you're
working as a prostitute yeah pretty much
or I would say a high-class escort at
that time because you know you had to
come with a great ex like appearance and
you had to dress a certain way you had
to look a certain way and you had to
wear makeup
um couldn't have any scars any tattoos
you know things of that sort
um
this was going on where
after I after dealing with the guy that
I was dealing with in what city
this hat this was happening in Ohio oh
in Ohio
um
I was in Ohio for maybe two years
because I was
like I didn't want to be there but it
started to feel like something that I
could do like you know it'd be okay with
it and I really wasn't okay with that
like you know what I mean
like because it was the luxury life
I was like
psychologically telling myself like I
could do this and I can do this for a
living and that's when I knew that this
wasn't okay you feel like you were
tricked manipulated coerced anything
into it definitely
definitely
um but what made me stay is definitely
the money then the money that we saw
but it wasn't until like I said two
years later I started to put up a fight
not physically but like verbally like
saying like I don't even want to do this
anymore
[Music]
um if you're saying that this is not
against our will let me go or whatever
and that turned out terrible because
they just ended up selling me to a lower
end
um person so after Ohio I was told to
someone in in Kentucky
and that was like
I would never go to Kentucky just based
off of that experience because they
literally treated the colored ones
like
like we were dogs like we literally were
treated like the men that were kind of
in control were Caucasian yes
um
and what city in Kentucky
especially if you put enough muffy's
yeah
um but how does it feel to be sold like
a
like like a dog like I keep referring to
it I literally all my life has have felt
like a dog that's been trained for
the line of that you know being used
sexually
but
um I'm trying to change that now how old
do you know 26 26. okay
are you still doing it no you're not
I've been out
my son is three so four and a half years
yeah how did you finally get out
believe it or not the FBI
but I'm not gonna go in that's often how
girls get out yeah Tim goes to prison
yeah
so
yeah we're not going to talk too much
about that but they found me and they
helped to be helping get my feet I was
in a couple of safe houses
so
how's your life changed since
you went through that and got out
um
it has definitely changed for the better
um
I have two beautiful sons
and
I make sure I take care of them every
day
um
love them
give them everything that I was looking
for as a young girl
um and a mom
I just want to make sure that I'm
nothing like what my mother was
so everything that I I didn't like
I'm trying to change but not put my
problems onto my children because they
have nothing to do with the things that
I've experienced before them
so I'm just trying to keep a
gray head on my shoulder
um and provide for them I'm in a good
relationship
both we are both together and I'm trying
to make sure that we stay together
because I believe that's important and
young boys lives
especially in a day and age that we're
in now that
it's not really it's heard of but it's
not something that people are looking
forward everyone wants to co-parent and
live their separate lives
um but I want to be with one person and
my children know one person
and
make it work yeah where drugs a part of
your life when this is gone definitely
so during that time you know you had to
have things that was like a pain
enhancer or a sex enhancer so
um
ecstasy Percocets oxycodone heroin
I've pretty much done it all besides PCP
yeah and crack
I haven't done Craig
no PCP everything else and you were able
to get away from those drugs
it was hard it was definitely hard
um
a couple times I had to do rehab and a
couple of times it was more of like like
from the heroine I had to do like Xanax
but like
five and then go to four and then go to
three then go to two then go to one then
go to half like you know I couldn't just
cold turkey myself off of that so
you feel like the reason this your life
went in that direction was because of
your mouth
I will say it is definitely
gave the ball the push and start
it definitely gave the ball a person
start I don't know if this is something
that was bound to happen in my life
but it it was definitely easier for the
others to take advantage because of that
because I felt like if if it happened
with my mom
like you know the person that brought me
into this world was supposed to love me
it could happen with anybody
and that was a terrible mindset to have
and I wish somebody would well not a lot
of people knew
a couple people knew but I just wish
those people said like you know that's
that's not what you here for that's not
the life that was made
for you yeah you were dealt something
but now I'm hearing it because I'm in
therapy so
that's what's changing everything is
actually you know being in therapy now
yeah that's that's great what is your
mom's situation currently
biological yeah
um I believe she's in rehab
I believe
I don't really talk to her I don't
really talk about her
um
yeah
pretty much dismissed the whole
situation
but
my siblings still has a relationship you
know what I mean well my two older ones
the other one's the younger siblings
they feel the same way like we just
didn't really matter or exist
only the two oldest did
but
hey hair loss
she's missing out on great kids and
great grandkids you know what I mean
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
definitely appreciated my adopted mom
I should have definitely said you know
am I allowed to curse sure
[ __ ] her you know
she decided the life that she wanted you
know if she didn't want to reach get
that relationship from me I shouldn't be
forcing myself to get a relationship
with her I should have left that alone
but I was young you know craving for a
love that I thought I wanted
nah definitely definitely good on that
now
you've been in love so far
have you been in love before yes I will
say I'm currently in love that's great
did you have any examples of a loving
relationship between no when you were a
kid no My adoptive mom was never married
um she had a relationship but that
wasn't like it was a long distance
relationship so we didn't get to see
your biological mom had eight kids yeah
how many different fathers all of us
besides that the twins everyone has a
different father
and Amber what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
love yourself
love yourself
you love yourself everything else will
fall into place you will lack
insecurities that hinder you
for certain things or take your risks
that you should be taking or shouldn't
be taking
um
honestly I just think loving yourself
and
trusting your own intuition and
abilities
is the main thing that makes you
successful you are your only
you're you are your only
obstacle honestly if you feel like you
can't jump over this camera it's because
you think you can't jump over the camera
you know what I mean
all right Amber thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I'm glad
things are going better for you thank
you thank you very much thanks